carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
bienvenidos a este programa especial que
les presentamos hoy desde el que un
líder parís museo que acoge en sus salas
a una de las civilizaciones antiguas más
extraordinarias y fascinantes que ha
tenido el continente americano y el
mundo los olmecas vivieron en el golfo
de méjico y legaron piezas de una
belleza y calidad extraordinarias que
descubriremos hoy en carrusel de las
artes
[Música]
parís se acoge la primera gran muestra
sobre los olmecas y las civilizaciones
del golfo de méjico una exposición que
reúne 300 piezas excepcionales muchas de
las cuales se ven por primera vez fuera
de su país de origen los olmecas fueron
especialistas de la escultura con
basalto y jade y de las cabezas
colosales una de ellas hizo el viaje
hasta la capital francesa y en nuestra
crónica musical fuimos al encuentro de
'pretty fans
el nuevo principito de la canción
francesa
[Música]
los olmecas y las civilizaciones del
golfo de méxico han tomado los espacios
del museo que von lee de parís y para
descubrir esta exposición vamos a
conversar hoy con el antropólogo steve
sawyer responsable de las colecciones de
américa de este museo estoy muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros en
nuestro programa carrusel de las artes
es verdaderamente esta exposición los
olmecas excepcional y por qué
es una exposición excepcional por varias
razones
esta primera vez que vamos a dar a
conocer las culturas de la zona del
golfo de méxico a un público a gobierno
entonces en esta exposición queremos
mostrar obras de arte y la cultura de
varios grupos culturales a través de
tres de una historia de tres mil años de
antigüedad entonces hay piezas de la
cultura olmeca pero también de las otras
culturas que habitaron la zona de el
golfo de méxico son piezas de una
calidad artística muy alta es
ciertamente una plaza de mostrar esas
cosas aquí en tal es este que está
enfrente de una de las 18 cabezas
colosales olmecas que se han descubierto
hasta ahora está específicamente viene
del sitio de san lorenzo hubo tres
grandes capitales de la civilización
olmeca y me parece que a través de esta
cabeza podemos descubrir un poco la
estética
es verdad es una esta cabeza colosal es
una de la más pequeña entonces es una es
la cabeza
una de las tardes de la exposición y
representa una probablemente el agosto
el de un dirigente olmeca con su casco
particular es una cabeza que mide un
metro ochenta y tres de altura y su peso
es más o menos de cuatro toneladas y
medio tiene varios significados el
primero es que es una piedra volcánica
extraída de las montañas de tus playas a
unos 80 kilómetros de distancia del
sitio de san lorenzo entonces eso es una
demostración del poder de ser capaz de
traer piezas toneladas de piedra al
sitio como tal no en realmente demostrar
el poder de manera muy clara
y también una manera de digamos
petrificar el poder y la cabeza con la
sal de este tipo los olmecas de esta
época generalmente la gente la más
popular
de mesoamérica esta exposición es que es
un esfuerzo conjunto del museo del cluny
de parís y de diversas instituciones
mexicanas entre ellas el museo de
antropología de méxico y justamente
fuimos al encuentro de la comisaria
mexicana cora falero ruiz quien nos dio
más detalles sobre esta exposición
la historiografía en torno a los olmecas
es una historiografía en construcción
son muy pocos años de estudio la primera
vez que se menciona el término el me
encajó en 1927 cuando un académico
empezó a encontrar similitudes en
distintos objetos que habían sido
encontrados para él quedó claro que se
trataba de una cultura no conocida antes
pero completamente identificable
es una de las culturas de la que menos
se sabe respecto al resto de las
culturas de mesoamérica es la más
antigua es la que se caracteriza por
estos grandes monolitos o estas grandes
esculturas
la piedra tiene un lenguaje la
materialidad indígena la materialidad
del mezcla también encierra muchos
significados la ofrenda más antigua al
meta fue encontrada en los 90s está aquí
en la exposición data está fechada en el
1600 antes de cristo
[Música]
para nosotros es muy significativo este
interés en este caso francés en términos
generales un interés extranjero en una
cultura que también en méxico es
totalmente reconocida identificable pero
cuya historia está en construcción
todavía entonces es una gran oportunidad
tanto para gméxico mostrar aspectos de
esa cultura como para el museo que
habrán de recibir una exposición de este
tipo
[Música]
seguimos en el museo del que von lee en
compañía de steve bourget para esta
exposición sobre los olmecas y las
culturas del golfo de méxico steve
hablábamos de esta cabeza colosal pero
me parece que en esta exposición hay
otras piezas muy importantes de la
civilización olmeca que pudieron hacer
el viaje de méxico hasta parís si
normalmente bueno eso es una exposición
y llenada de piezas extraordinarias para
decir entre ellas hay por ejemplo el
señor de las limas una escultura de
argentina de jardín que tiene que mide
unos 55 centímetros de altura y que
representan casanare teniendo en sus
brazos un dios
'la meca' quizás el día más antiguo
seguramente lo más famoso de la cultura
olmeca se ve un grupo de escultor
llamado los azules los cuales son un par
de gemelos en una calidad de la
escultura muy muy alta
también hay una pieza que ella pide esta
pieza por mi propio
voy a decir la verdad es una de las
piezas más bellas del arte olmeca suena
lo que se llama el luchador olmeca
empieza en un personaje así con en
posición de fuerza pero es muy si es muy
probablemente un tipo de persona que
esté que va a transformarse en un ser
jaguar es una pieza increíble que tiene
unos 80 centímetros de altura muy lindo
y es verde mente la star del museo
nacional de antropología de méxico
entonces agradezco muchísimo el director
el agente del museo por haber estado
leal esta pieza famosa que hay muchas
cosas por descubrir de los olmecas steve
toneladas
literalmente mis colegas mexicanos me
han dicho que hay algunos más de 70
proyectos arqueológicos en marcha en
este momento en la zona olmeca
entonces hay muchos proyectos hay mucho
para descubrir por colegas mexicanos
mire usted que cuando estamos en frente
de una pieza así uno piensa que tiene
tres mil años de antigüedad se podría
decir que el hombre siempre buscó la
belleza siempre busco algo ideal si yo
pienso que siempre hemos hecho cosas
maravillas hemos hecho unas bebidas y
siempre hemos tenido
mikel ángelus gente que tenían o como se
decía en español manitas de plata es esa
la calidad de una manera de trabajar las
piedras y lo que queremos entre otras
cosas didácticas antropológicas lo que
queremos que la gente vea en la
exposición es la belleza de las piezas
pensar a la calidad muy alta del trabajo
antiguo también es la misma calidad que
reconocemos hoy hoy en día es decir que
no son gente primitiva son nosotros
solamente como nosotros
pero en época remota en otras dos
tiempos
digamos con estas palabras tan
inspiradas stephen moyer le vamos a
agradecer por habernos recibido en este
museo del que volví para esta exposición
los olmecas y las civilizaciones del
golfo de mexico que puede verse aquí
hasta el julio del 2000 del 21 y ahora
vamos a pasar a nuestra crónica musical
[Música]
vaya
el principito lo que ocupas es el nombre
del personaje de la obra distante
pero también el nombre del seudónimo de
él ya que no recibe aquí en el estudio
de grabación gracias por recibirnos de
nada
primera pregunta porque ese seudónimo
ese apodo de 'el principito' fue un
apodo que me habían dado unos amigos por
mi cabello rubio y mi lado un poco
ingenuo y lo adopté en el momento en que
tenía que elegir un nombre art y es un
poco como un tatuaje al principio era
extraño y al final lo adopté
[Música]
y en este nuevo álbum que se llama tribu
mata las más bonitas mañanas la vamos a
traducir así hay temas melancólicos como
por ejemplo son restos que han apego
cansino a que se puede traducir como
perro chino donde sacas tú esa
inspiración con reconoce ejerce tal vez
cuando comenzó a escribir este álbum
comencé grabando una primera melodía
mientras grababa escuché los ronquidos
de mi perra
josephine que es un perro shar pei un
perro chino perros que hacen mucho ruido
cuando duermen entonces escribí sobre
ella y luego quise mantener esa ternura
de mi intimidad en el álbum porque vivo
en parís una ciudad estresante un poco
dura donde hay presión social si quería
hablar de mi perro tierno de los amigos
de mi novia quería hablar de mi pequeño
capullo porque este es mi primer arte un
cuc un revival
con álbum
como podría resumir o explicar este
ambiente musical tuyo
cuando cantas en francés siempre tienes
que poner la voz un poco más fuerte por
razones inexplicables pero es así creo
que hago música pop francesa podemos
decir psicodélica también porque utilizó
muchas texturas diferentes pero lo que
define mi música es de todo un poco
porque no tengo un solo instrumento como
la batería o la guitarra y busco sonidos
a través de todos mis instrumentos de
hecho podríamos decir que estoy a medio
camino entre el rock y la música
electrónica
luego qué
[Música]
con salidas
gracias natal y olivares y así vamos a
despedir este programa especial en el
museo del que volví de parís
muchísimas gracias por haber pasado este
momento con nosotros cuídense mucho
favor
[Música]